[Music]
you will need to design a path that
connects the critical infrastructure
those orange nodes using the least
amount of cable the winning team will be
the one that uses the least amount of
cable but remember you'll be penalized
for doubling back and cutting across
blocks so plan your network carefully
today's challenge is all about Network
Theory which is the mathematics of
interconnected objects and their
relationships an effective solution will
create a minimum spanning tree that will
wire up your city in the most efficient
manner essentially measure carefully and
let the algorithm do the rest so like I
said any set of objects that are
connected together we can represent as a
mathematical Network and actually throw
some things at me right I haven't told
you what A B C D and E are and all that
kind of thing what could these we call
them nodes or vertices what could they
represent what kinds of objects might be
connected in this way suggestions house
houses okay so these could be houses and
they're connected by roads give me
another one a social network fantastic
so they could be people and these are
like you know relationships they could
be by friendship family they could be
marriage Etc okay give me another one
objects in a house objects in-house so
maybe for example these could be like
appliances and they're all connected to
each other wirelessly maybe they could
be computers now I or if you play this
game for a long time right maybe they
could be um stations in a trained
Network maybe they could be we talked
about relationships before maybe they
could be human beings but maybe they're
not relationships maybe it's about say
for example something we've all gotten
familiar over the last two and a half
years these could be connections of a
disease transferring from person to
person right maybe they could be animals
in a food web right my whole point in
giving this sort of prologue is Network
Theory even though it's sort of simple
mathematics it's so useful because it
can apply to anything right anytime you
have things in relationship we use the
mathematics of networks now you are
going to be working in a city that looks
a little bit like this these are going
to be nodes that we want to connect with
power okay so it's kind of like an
electrical grid except things have
broken down we need to reconnect things
and even though like the normal
functioning City everything's sort of
you know you've got multiple paths
between things we call them edges these
these lines what we want to do is get
everything white up as quickly as
possible as efficiently as possible so
that we can at least get everyone back
up to some minimum working sort of
arrangement or setup okay so what you're
going to do
is within all of these different options
and these might be actually distances
right so the city may not look
physically like this you might have see
this is 14 and this is four those might
be the actual distances between them but
if I put them on a map you know some
some of these things that are very close
together very close together it's just
hard to understand the relationships
between them so that's why I've just
sort of arranged it like this but the
numbers tell you how far apart things
are or what the cost is like maybe see
how this is 14. maybe it's not that it's
far but you actually have to say tunnel
through Rock to get there so it's
difficult right the whole idea is it's
cost in some way shape or form
so I'm going to teach you an algorithm
it's called prim's algorithm that's a
very basic idea that will help you to
create what we call a minimum spanning
tree which sounds like a bit of a
mouthful but it's exactly what it sounds
like a tree is just a connection of all
of these things it's spanning which
means it's going to get to everything A
to B to C all the way through to I and
it's minimum we want to have the
shortest distance possible or the
shortest cost right
and one of the cool things about this
algorithm is you can start anywhere
right we could start on I or F if you
wanted to but just because I think it
might be a little easier for us to
follow let's start at a now if we're
over here we're eventually are going to
connect everything together and prim's
algorithm just says looked for the
lowest costs for any of the different
nodes around right so when you look at a
it can connect to B and H which is the
lowest cost B let's just be right
because that's four so we could say all
right this
this Edge is going to be part of my
minimum spanning tree now I'm going to
keep on doing this but I'm going to also
not just keep track of where I can
connect to but where I was before so you
can see there's an 8 here and an eight
here and an 11. so of those options
either of those eights are identical
right so let's just keep going and see
where we get up to
if I join that up now again look at
where my my sort of uh baby tree has
started and where it can grow toward
what's the next node that has the lowest
cost I I ah now C is C to D is is less
than what we've done before but C to I
is certainly the cheapest so you can see
I'm going to start to form this down
here and I'm just going to kind of
progress through I've got a well you
have it look and tell me what's the next
one it's going to be
because that's the six like so
what's going to be next yes it's the
cheapest one along the whole thing
because remember it's yeah anywhere
connected I'm here it's
um G to H isn't it right so I'll do that
and now you can see just as I pause here
right
I could have connected a to H at the
start but this is actually a cheaper way
to go about it because I had to use
these I had to be connected to them in
the end so this one maybe they're like
right next to each other or there's some
existing wiring that I can just use and
that makes it very cheap okay and I
guess let's try and finish it off right
where would you go next from here
yeah I think F that two
right there I've got 10 14 4 so it looks
like that thing though is going to
connect you back to something you've
already done so you don't need that do
you so have a look again let's see today
very good so that's seven which we
abandoned before because you're like ah
I've got a two available now it's the
cheapest option to something that isn't
connected yet going back here is kind of
silly and redundant right it's not going
to give me a Minimum spanning tree so
let's go up here
I'm pretty close aren't I I only have e
to connect up so which is the cheapest
way to do it nine
D to F that's nine
have a quick check for me is everything
joined up
yeah yes okay so now we have a spanning
tree and you can actually go ahead and
you can test this out you could say rub
that out try a different option maybe
you decide oh you know how we did this
one we chose between this one and this
one right maybe you say well let's give
the other one a go and see if we end up
with something that's cheaper that
actually gets us a more efficient answer
that's the way the algorithm works it's
not complicated but it does rely on
having all of these numbers doesn't it
we're not going to give you those
numbers you're going to have to work
that part out but that'll be part of
your planning stage and then I mean not
just draw it you're actually going to go
and do this wiring physically and you'll
have to be careful when you do it okay
this challenge is all about Network
Theory which is the mathematics of
interconnected objects and their
relationships an effective solution will
create a minimum spanning tree that will
wire up your city in the most efficient
manner measure carefully and let the
algorithm do the rest
[Music]